hello went welcome turns video GM get a
guess I think I had to miss the day on
this in the stream right he said we
played this and he had a very good
position against me I have to improve
somehow but ok this is a different line
maybe he has looked up something
actually okay castles is not so critical
Queenie to is the more threatening move
okay let you force it's the thing oh
just immediately goes for trades let's
do it it's not a bad ending here the
light on g4 is quite nice okay let's use
the square tau d 6 and you can take now
and make my bone structure look quite
funny but ok it's not very aggressive
and here maybe I'm maybe I can take him
take this Bishop now so just here for
the bishop pair if i go to d2 well
bishop t2 i have h for some ok either
they don't want
takes root chicks is annoying because
the head doesn't have f3 maybe you can
ignore before because of Bishop f3 now
that's very much possible yep I gave 95
though yeah just be an annoyance yeah I
came so I Jacqueline to grab my grab the
bishop pair here pawn takes that looks
kind of nice how to do this now should
83 and like to double of course let's
start with this knight c6 sound that
that's far too greedy and King edge to a
bishop age three and so yeah okay bishop
i three kings III maybe you can make
this work somehow but it looks scary it
looks like a scary position for a while
yeah so he tried to make it work so
Bishop age three at the end ents on h4 I
am hmm ok I can also play Bishop to a
six-foot rook edge one is very likely
fine if I play Bishop a pre-check King
g3 rock 2 h8 is going to play it's going
to play rock edge one then don't have
something they are amazingly enough
I know I really don't agree don't know
here g5 trying to use the look on the
fourth ranking but i'm unsure about
everything yeah now i have to take it
home yeah probably that wasn't such a
great idea now it wasn't a great idea
thinking of five stuff here yeah it is
still not doing that much
yeah I cannot do much I spoiled it
somehow and I think this was a nice
position but I did something something I
have to have to improve somewhere so I'm
trying to say
ladies rooty five who got 5 it the
opposite colored bishops here they make
the sister this very dry yeah maybe here
and then g6 his rook is a bit off but
now it's not it's not very dangerous i
have anything for him getting ready for
work age 50 pitches the draw
check I may be Bishop before something
that I should have paid attention to
one minute left garage hi all right yep
it was a bit stupid there that I didn't
pay attention to this Queen age seven
now after all I said rook age five but
not when the bishop is there hmm that's
actually a problem
check yeah that was entirely necessary
it was typically at the moment where you
decide okay this is going to be a draw
you're not going to win this game blah
blah blah it's the Lord way you have to
have to look again yeah and not just and
play any move check it was a position
that you cannot lose normally but I
simply didn't look at this particular
moment
it can take the second pone down because
he always has those checks and
discoveries check black forfeits on time
well I didn't I didn't pay attention to
the time yeah there was a very City Los
completely unnecessary especially
considering that around here whites
position is actually very bad but I
couldn't I couldn't find the right way
of doing it now that says move it's one
of the good moves my black is better
here in many ways free it shouldn't be
about one or two moves this is not so
good for black it doesn't have a good
good square to go to and this is
actually quite strong have courses is
strong because he cannot go to you two
very important to is the normal move but
this is looser Shannon do this stuff and
if he goes like here check and I can do
this actually and then look edge look
here and so on this is fantastic yeah so
so c5 was strong the engine wants to
play this and after which black is just
fantastically better this is very weak
yeah this was the moment I simply didn't
find a good way here and I mean here
it's okay but it's not it's not
convincing and maybe yeah maybe maybe
this this is what the engine wants to do
and again like is in good shape
yeah I kind of I kind of that ok let's
let's make a draw which the position of
course is but check the moment when I
actually said ok let's dance offer the
draw i blundered into the rope move this
is just stupid when I suppose what I
offer to draw yeah when you can just do
whatever you just have to avoid this and
if you have what this you can never lose
and here it's a child I ostium check so
impossible to hold them given the doctor
a bonus is too much the hip bone is too
much ok well thanks for watching